So I want to finalize our conversation about
Donald Trump getting impeached a second time, as
we've been filming, the House has started to move
forward with what I described earlier, an initial
proposal for the 25th Amendment to be invoked.
Every indication that that is not going to happen
and that impeachment will be subsequently the
path forward. We also spoke earlier about how some
Republican officials now say that it's time for
Trump to go even that he should be impeached. We
talked about Pat Toomey saying Trump should leave.
We talked about Chris Christie saying that that
Trump's inciting of the violent insurrection is
certainly impeachable. But where is the public
on this? That's the next question. And we do have
new polling on that. According to a new Reuters
Ipsos poll, 57 percent of Americans want Donald
Trump to be immediately removed from office. This
is sort of like a do not pass go, do not collect
200 dollars type of thing. And it is, of course,
directly related to his encouragement of the
protests last week, which escalated into a deadly
riot inside the U.S. Capitol building. Most of the
people who want Trump removed are still Democrats.
Republicans remain much more supportive of Donald
Trump, and seven out of 10 of those who voted for
Trump in November oppose his removal. But again,
when it's only 70 percent of Republicans who are
against the removal, you end up with a situation
where, led by Democrats, with many independents
and some Republicans, the majority of the country,
it's not disapproves of the job Trump is doing.
It's believes that Donald Trump should be removed.
So there's a few different aspects to this
one. Yes, it's notable that so many people
in the country want the president removed.
But what's the other side of that? It's the
same as what we've been saying when we've
looked at Donald Trump's approval over
the last four years. How is it this low?
In other words, it should be dramatically, more
than slightly more than half of Americans wanting
the president removed. The exact number
right now is 57 percent. When you blend
Democrats, independents and Republicans, you
end up with about 57 percent of Americans
wanting Trump to leave office. What about the
rest of them? And it's disappointingly low.
And I think it's important to remember, you
know, we've talked today about this idea that
impeachment could be divisive or whatever the case
and how I think those are really bad arguments.
I think there's another aspect to this that's
important to to broach or to bring up. Once again,
impeachment is not about punishment.
Impeachment is what you do when the facts
say that it's warranted and if the facts
say that it's warranted, it must be done.
And one of the reasons I've seen some be hesitant
to support impeachment is they don't believe it
would be a sufficient punishment because Trump
is leaving anyway. I think that that's both not
the point and also irrelevant because there is
a mechanism through which the Senate can vote
if the House and the Senate can vote to convict,
but they can also vote to strip Trump of the
ability to run in the future. And that requires
only a simple majority. And there are more things
at stake. There is Trump's million dollar a year
presidential travel budget. There are
other things that are at play here. So
for the folks saying the impeachment wouldn't be
a strict enough punt, it wouldn't really be much
of a punishment for Trump at this point. No.
One, I disagree in that being impeached and if
particularly if he was convicted or stripped of
the ability to run again would be humiliating for
Donald Trump. And that's a it's quite a punishment
when you understand Donald Trump's psyche. There
are also other things that would be significantly
deleterious to Donald Trump's future. But again,
it is not about punishment. Trump's mishandling
of coronavirus is impeachable. Trump's inciting
of this riot is impeachable. And if he did
something impeachable, he must be impeached. So
I'm tired of it would be divisive or it wouldn't
be much of a punishment mindset. I'm also, by the
way, tired of the mindset that we can just keep
him under control for the next however many days.
It's not about that at this point in time. And
it's not true. No one has been able to keep him
under control for any period of time. I mean, look
at look at even last week he incited the riot.
Then he was essentially, from what we
know, forced to go out there and say,
oh, the violence was bad and there
will be a transition like, oh, wow,
he sounds slightly presidential. It was
obviously disingenuous. And within hours,
he was back on Twitter repeating the
same failed, the same debunked notions
about voter fraud and 75 million votes and all
of this other stuff so nobody can control him.
It's not about that. It's not about punishment.
It's just what has to happen. And more than half
of the country at this point believes that Donald
Trump should be immediately removed from power.